So, you guys sent us this
cool Hello World logo.
Yeah, you can see that this is a bed.
Very cool.
Of your Hello World and Bloomberg rockets.
Yeah, because we just sent
you like a 2D drawing.
Yes, exactly.
Of our hopes and dreams.
Yeah.
Now we're going to turn
this model into sugar.
Welcome to Sugar Lab,
where Kyle von Hasseln
and his team are looking to
shape sugar into edible art.
They do it with this homegrown
first of its kind machine.
Send them a design and they'll candify it
as many times as you'd like.
I'm just realising now
this is like "The Jetsons."
Yeah, totally.
Just push button.
Super futuristic.
Get food.
After the design is approved,
a quick control P sends it over here.
Super proud of this.
This is the current 3D printer.
We designed and built it from scratch.
You can see like it looks like
a kind of commercial kitchen equipment.
But it also contains all of the processes
that we're familiar
with, with 3D printing.
It manages this dry powder,
which is starch and sugar
and then we've got a print head over here
which moves across and
actually prints the object.
We actually jet liquid water
and alcohol into the surface,
along with food dye.
And by jetting just the right amount,
we create this picture perfect image
of the object at that cross section.
Yeah, so these are the
Hello World rockets.
That's pretty cool!
I know it's just air, but
that's still somehow exciting.
Yeah.
Since reaching peak
hype a decade or so ago,
3D printers have found a
solid niche in manufacturing,
making shapes that are too tricky
for traditional methods.
The technology has been used to print
wild high cuisine creations
and to squish lab grown meat
cells into pleasing forms.
The idea, I confess, does not
exactly make my mouth water
and walking into sugar
lab, I was sceptical.
But that was before I met Chef Jonathan
and tried his tasting menu.
Yeah, so we have a nice
assortment of different things.
We have dealer's choice here.
Okay.
I got some chocolate covered sushis.
Just your classic skull?
Just your classic Shakespearian skull.
Okay, it's sweet,
but it's not as sweet as I kind of
thought it was gonna be, yeah.
Exactly.
You know, really like
and just sickening sweet.
But it's not, it's like more
meringue like in texture.
That is what I was looking for.
It's like a meringue.
These look like everlasting Gobstoppers,
but they are not.
No, they're not everlasting Gobstoppers.
They're never lasting Gobstoppers.
That's very good.
Yeah.
I just want to put that out there.
They won't last forever
if you buy these, so.
Oh, it's cool.
You get the colour and you get the fizz.
Give it a little stir.
Can it taste?
Yeah!
Is it safe to drink this much glitter?
Yeah, it's totally food
safe, edible glitter.
But there was more.
We have a strawberry covered chocolate.
And more.
A cranberry Frankenstein.
One of our nineties bonbon shells.
Little matcha Buddha for you.
Hazy IPA ganache.
Bonbon, glitter skull.
Our happy little pencil bonbon.
We got our fun little octopus there.
Our favourite boat, drink drops.
It's sparkles.
Green tea bonbon.
That's really good.
Holy .
It's like a layer upon layer
of magical bits and pieces.
Totally.
And finally, the 3D piece de resistance.
Yeah.
This one we made in ginger.
It's kinda like more subtle
too than you would expect.
I mean, it's just, it's very pure,
kind of the platonic form
of ginger, but it's not-
Insane.
Exactly.
Yeah, I did not ever think
I would be eating a rocket.
You should send this to space.
Oh yeah.
I know people.
Still, a ginger rocket ship
is just the culinary start.
As long as something can
be dehydrated into powder,
this team can print it.
So obviously you sell kinda end things
to businesses and consumers.
But then you,
the idea is to sell the
actual machines themselves?
Yeah.
So these 3D printers can go
into any commercial kitchen
in the US and even across the globe
and we're gonna start
selling them this year.
Okay, like I feel like
this is every Michelin star
chef is gonna have one
of these things that-
Yeah.
We've done stories on
synthetic meats in the past,
like protein grown in a vat.
Now I'm picturing like.
We could absolutely print meat here.
That's totally true.
So you could make like a chicken orange.
Yeah.
Or something like that.
Yeah, we've done some
weird mashups like that.
Yeah.
The detail and the colour here means
that we can create something
that maybe looks like a lemon,
but tastes like a dehydrated
pineapple or something.
Yeah.
After scarfing this much sugar,
I may need these guys to
3D print me a new pancreas.
But I'm happy to report that the food
of the future is more
delicious than you might think.